okay welcome back we're gonna have
another R session now and uh today we're
going to explore
um fit in non-linear functions
um using R and once again we're gonna we
can actually work within the rstudio
um markdown environment which I showed
you last time which allows us to
document what we're doing and produce a
nice web document that that records
everything we've done the output of our
function calls and the graphics that we
produced so this is a very easy way of
documenting sessions in R both for
yourself and people that you for whom
you're doing the analysis
so
we uh in we go
just to remind you if you want to learn
a little bit about our markdown if you
click on this button over here up on the
right you'll get the help and it just
gives you a very brief overview of all
the simple
um
commands and and ways of of of
indenting highlighting and so on the
main things we need to know
okay so let's get going we'll once again
require ISL or our library with data
sets
and we'll attach the dataset wage the
data frame wage okay
so the first thing we're going to look
at is is polynomials polynomial
regression
and we'll do a regression of the
response wage on age and we'll fit a
fourth degree polynomial
now normally that would require building
up a matrix of with columns x x squared
x cubed x to the fourth and then using
your regression function well this is
where R really comes before we have this
lovely formula language which lets us
just in one equation here we've got a
function poly which automatically
generates that basis for us and we tell
it to take as input age and 4 is the
degree that'll make the Matrix and then
LM will fit the model with response wage
and so it just all happens for us okay
and then we do a summary of the fit
and you'll see below we get the summary
sort of shortened space here but the
usual kinds of summaries that we get
from LM we get the formula
summary of the residuals and then the
coefficients and we see that
the
coefficients they all named polyh4 and
then one two three and four this will be
for degree one two three and four the
the different degree monomials the first
two are very significant the cubic is is
significant and the cortic is just
barely not significant okay so it seems
like a cubic polynomial would would be
sufficient
now normally you can't when you have a
whole Matrix you can't
just look at these coefficients
independently usually what it means is
the effect of say this coefficient in
the presence of all the others and if
the variables are correlated you you
know you you just can't make sequential
decisions but yeah it's a little
different
um and that's because
the function poly generates orthogonal
polynomials so it's like we do in a
regression with uncorrelated predictors
and we'll get back to that again in a
little moment
um
let's what we want to do now is make a
plot of the function we're usually not
interested in this individual
coefficients of a polynomial but we're
interested in the function that it's
produced okay so we're going to go
through the steps now of how to actually
produce that that plot so we tell our
studio that we the next segment is going
to have a figure and well we need to if
we want to specify the width and height
of the figure we we add that in the
little opening
um incantation there
and so now we're going to set up for our
plot so first of all we want to get the
range of age
and so we'll just use the function range
to get age limbs that gives us Returns
the vector of length 2 with the maximum
minimum and maximum
and now we use the function seek to make
a grid of values of age so age dot grid
will go seek from equals age limbs 1 2
equals age limits two so that's the
minimum to the maximum
and by default SQL just make a sequence
of numbers incrementing by one each time
unless you tell it otherwise since ages
are integer values here that'll just be
fine for us
we can
execute this
and let's just look at age dot grid
below here
and there you see a sequence of
incrementing by one each time
okay so now we're going to make
predictions so we'll predict from fit
and then we tell it that the new data
which has got to be a data frame or a
list at least with named variables that
were used in the original fit and since
age is the one that was used in the foot
and that's where we want to make
predictions we say new data equals list
age equals age dot grid and then we also
tell it that we want standard errors
okay
um your preds now will be a component a
a list with two components and one will
be fit and one will be
um
se.fit okay
so now we're gonna
make the standard error bands that we're
gonna we're gonna make a plot with a
fitted function and plus or minus two
standard error bands so here we make the
standard error bands
so we call we're going to make a matrix
with two columns so we call the function
C bind which is a way of making Binding
Together columns to make a matrix
and it's going to have two columns the
first one is going to be preds dollar
fit so that's a fitted function plus two
times the standard error
which also comes from print and then the
next column is going to be preds dollar
fit minus two times the standard error
so that can that's going to give us our
standard error bands
so we send that down to the process
and now we make our plot so we'll plot
age the first plot the data so age
versus wage and we'll make a dark gray
so there we get the plot
and now we'll do lines of of the we'll
use the lines function
to plot against H dot grid the the
predicted function
and we make it in blue
and line width equals two
is how you control the thickness of the
of the plot and by default the line
width is one
and then we use a function matte lines
which in this case we've got the single
X which is age dot grid but we've got
our two column Matrix that have the
standard error bands and you can use a
function mat lines to to plot those both
simultaneously and again we want them
blue and we say line type equals two
which means a broken line and so there
you see the fitted function plus or
minus two standard errors and so now
we're done so that's typically what we'd
like to produce when we fit a polynomial
we'd like to see the fitted function
and it's done for us with a little bit
of work we've had to do essentially
construct the function in the standard
error bands and we will see later on
that the the gam package has nice ways
of doing that for us without us going
through all the work
now
the other ways to fit polynomials we
didn't have to use our poly our poly
function for example you can fit it
directly so here we're going to fit the
polynomial directly by this specifying H
squared H cubed in h to the fourth
and so here's the the call to LM
um each of the terms separated by a plus
now notice we've had to wrap H squared
in in a function the identity function
we've seen this one before I believe and
that's because the the power sign this
carrot has a special meaning in a
formula and so if we wanted just to mean
squared we need to protect it and we do
that by wrapping it in the identity
function
so that'll for the degree fourth
polynomial
and
if we do a summary what we'll see is we
see the the four the four variables H
squared H cubed and H to the fourth
and the P values the coefficients and
the P values are different to what we
saw before
that's because we're using a different
basis for representing the the
polynomials
all right so if you change the basis you
get different coefficients and therefore
you'll get different P values
um
that you may that may sound a little
disconcerting but the real thing we're
interested in is a fitted polynomial and
as we'll see that hasn't changed okay
so we can just check that crudely by
just doing a plot of the fit from our
original polynomial which we'll just
extract by fitted so it just takes a
fitted it will extract the fitted values
that they observe at the given X's the
given values of age when we fit the
function and we'll plot that against
fitted of fit a and you see a perfectly
straight line which says those fitted
values are the same so the fitted
polynomial was the same but the
representation was different
um
so as I mentioned earlier by using the
orthogonal polynomials we can test each
of the coefficients separately
um
and and again if we look at the summary
of the foot we can separately look at
the significance of each of those
coefficients and decide which ones are
not needed in this case it was just the
the cubic
now
orthogonal polynomials are convenient
they considered a better way of fitting
polynomials
um
um but this idea of testing separately
only works if that's the only term in
the model and if it's not a glm it
doesn't work so it's got a limited use
more generally if you want to test
whether say a one degree polynomial is
better than another degree you need to
use the more General Anova function
and so that's going to be true for
example if you have other variables in
the model so here we have a simple
sequence
foot a is a linear model just with
education
foot B has got education and age both
trying to predict wage
and Fitzy has is a linear model with
education and a polynomial of degree two
in in age
and for D is the same but the polynomial
of degree 3 in age
so that's a nested sequence of models a
nested in complexity
in other words the second model contains
the first as a special case
likewise the third contains the second
and the first is special cases and so on
so that's called a nested sequence and
then we use the Anova function to sort
out which ones we need
and so
this is the output of an over
and what it tells us is that certainly
age is needed in the model with
education
also H squared is certainly needed as
well as age in the model
and but age cubed is not necessarily
needed it's not quite significant
well it's significant at the five
percent level but it's kind of marginal
so using a Nova like this to test nested
sequences of models is the right way to
go in general
so this has all been using um squared
error loss and fitting linear
regressions now we can of course use the
same technology to fit
um
to fit other models such as logistic
regressions
and so to do that we'll make a a binary
response if you recall in the in the
figure with uh
um of of wage versus age there was a
band at the top it's just get it back up
on the on the screen there was a band at
the top
um
of high wage earners let's see where's
our where's our plot here we go we'll
put that plot up again
there's a there's a band up at the top
here of high wage earners and it looks
like if we thresholded around 250 we'll
capture those guys and we're going to
call those the ones and the rest are
going to be zero so it'll be a
relatively small group of ones
um that we're going to turn that into a
binary response
so let's find our place again
okay and so here we are so we can do
that on the Fly again we use our
indicator function and there we just
provide the conditional wage bigger than
250. well that evaluates to a true false
variable but if you coerce that to
numeric it'll be a zero one variable and
so that all just happens for us here
and so that is going to be modeled as a
polynomial in age with degree equals
three and we do that and we fit that
using glm until it family equals
binomial
and again we can do the summary of the
fit
and
it
it gives us a summary of coefficients
and now because it's a glm even though
the polynomial was orthogonal is an
orthogonal basis it's no longer
strictly orthogonal when we fit a glm
because there's different glm involves
having weights for the observations and
and so the orthogonality is somewhat
lost
and so if we really want to do the test
for example if a polynomial of degree 3
was needed we'd have to fit another glm
with a polynomial of degree two and test
to see if the two were different
um we can get standard error bands as
well just like before
so we'll first make a prediction
of prints
and we'll ask for standard errors
and yeah we do things slightly
differently we make standard error bands
um some being a little trickier
we want preds Dollar Foot to be in the
middle of the standard error bands so
that's just a single vector and here are
C bind three things together
just a zero
and I name them as well fit equals zero
lower equals minus two times spread
stand dollar standard error and up
equals plus two times spread standard
error so these are just this is a zero
and the minus two standard there isn't a
plus two standard errors so two things
are happening here these are two vectors
of length n
if you include a scalar like zero in C
bind it'll just replicate it n times so
this will make a three column Matrix
okay and then we add to it a single
Vector an N vector and that'll just get
replicated three times so it adds it to
each of the columns
so that's a little bit of trickery
um
but it's good to learn tricks
and let's look at this Matrix that's
resulted we'll look at the first five
rows and there we can see it's done
exactly what we said
um and so in the
over here is the is the fit itself this
is going to be the lower and this is
this is the upper and this is going down
with values of age
um
so that gives the standard errors on um
for the the fitted values well actually
the the predict predict fits the um
linear predictor for us so that's on the
loaded scale
um we're usually more interested in on
the in the predictions on the
probability scale especially if we fit
in against a single variable
um
and so we want to do the conversion
so yeah I've got an expression we need
to do the inverse loaded which I've got
an expression here that's written in
latex
um and if you know latex
or yeah it says Tech but it's a tech
language if you know if you know Tech or
latex you'll know what this means what
this is mainly shown you is that you can
embed Tech and latex expressions in in
markdown
and it will format properly so instead
of waiting to show you the formatted
document I'm in a I'm going to run it
right now you see it it runs through the
whole document and then it produces the
output and because I really want to show
you what that formula ended up looking
like once we formatted it with latex
so here's all the output of everything
we've done so far and there we have it
so it's formatted in a mathematical
formula so if you know how to use Tech
you'll know how to do that and you'll
see now you can embed that directly in
the markdown
if you didn't know about tech
don't be worried it's a it's a very
popular language used for most people
who do mathematical work convenient way
of of typesetting
so we want to apply that transformation
to both our fitted function and the
upper and lower standard error bands to
to transform them to the probability
scale
and so in R this is how we do it and
we're going to apply that inverse logit
function so you see it's e to the
SC bands over 1 plus e to the SC bands
or exponential of SC bands it's going to
do this simultaneously to all the
elements of the Matrix and return a
matrix for us which is exactly what we
want here
and now we can make a plot
and so we do it
um
I have
limited the range here because the
standard error bands are now new in
advance we're going to be very wide and
we're going to squashed the plot down so
this is the estimate of the fitted
probability
and and this is an estimated confidence
interval 95 percent confidence interval
for the fitted probability
so now you see the value of doing it on
the loaded scale
the confidence bands first computed on
the loaded scale and then transformed to
the probability scale and what you get
for that is that your standard error
bands for the probabilities all lie
within zero and one so this guy never
gets below zero it's wedged in at zero
but never gets below zero and that's
kind of what you'd like okay and now we
add some points to show where the data
occur
um and they'll appear there they are and
and I've actually what I've done here is
I first of all use Jitter of age because
there were lots of ties in age at each
of the integer values of age to give an
indication of how many how much data
occurred at each age I used the Jitter
function which randomly adds to each
element of the vector age a little bit
of uniform random noise so you can get
an idea of the density so there are
these zeros they're the ones
to have them fit on the page since I'd
limited the scale to up to 0.1 which
means that we can see here only four
percent at most of the population in any
given age category earned above 250k
we had to limit the range we had to
shrink down the ones to point to make
them point one so we can include them
and just see them in the plot okay so
this is similar to a plot we have in the
in the book and it shows the fitted
probability
okay
so we've learned how to use polynomials
we've learned how to compare different
polynomials and we've learned how to
plot the fitted functions with the
standard error bands and we've also
learned how to use them with glms as
well as linear models
so in the next segment we're going to
look at different functions we're going
to look at splines which are more
General functions
usually better behaved than polynomials
and we're going to see how to fit
splines both with single variables and
with multiple variables using the gam
package